the last segment we talked quickly about
Kirsten Nilson being fired Stephen
Miller's cruelty being the point that's
what he dreams about being cruel at the
border and Donald Trump but we briefly
mentioned the illegal actions that the
president was asking border agents to
carry out we briefly alluded to it but I
want you to take a look at this video of
acting White House chief of staff Mick
Mulvaney as he makes it clear that the
president is going to break the law in
another way they knew they were they're
not going to get these these taxes they
know what the law is they know that one
of the fundamental principles of the IRS
is to protect the confidentiality of you
and me and everybody else who files
taxes they know that they know the terms
under law by which the IRS can give them
the documents but political political
hit job is not one of those reasons so
they know there to be clear you believe
Democrats will never see the president's
tax returns
oh no never no nor should they okay so
Mick Mulvaney has made it clear that the
president despite Congress asking for
the president's tax returns in a very
formal and illegal fashion that the
president will never turn over his tax
returns
now you can debate about what's going to
turn up is there anything in there the
substantive are the Democrats just
playing political games you all can
debate that as much as you want what's
important here is for us to realize that
we have a President of the United States
who is willing to look at the law and
simply say I'm going to ignore it the
the request that was made it was made
last week by the House Ways and Means
Committee Chairman Richard Neal he
formally requested it using he was
citing a an old old IRS code but it's
legal nonetheless which gives the
chairman of the House and Ways and Means
Committee the ability to request the IRS
turn over tax returns for basically
anybody now you can argue whether or not
you think that code is legal or whether
it's appropriate or whether it should be
overturned but rather it is legal and so
he
using little law to make a formal
request of the IRS and the IRS actually
has until tomorrow the 10th to respond
now this doesn't mean that Trump can't
challenge this Trump can challenge this
in court Trump does have the ability to
push back against this but for Mick
Mulvaney to go out and simply say that
they're never going to get it despite
the fact that there is an IRS code that
allows the House Ways and Means
Committee Chairman to request this tax
return shows you just how unlawful this
administration really is and quite
frankly how giddily how happily they are
about being able to just do whatever
they want to do and the belief that they
are above the law this is very clear and
Attorney General Holder former attorney
General Holder sees it much the same way
he said on yesterday via Twitter he said
quote really two questions in referring
in reference to Mick Mulvaney he said
what is he hiding and on exactly what
basis of the Trump administration going
to lawfully not disclose the tax returns
in response to a legitimate
congressional request this is a direct
affront to the rule of law serious
precisely the case right when you couple
this with the illegal when you couple
the fact that Trump is going to ignore
of the requests of Congress right Mick
Mulvaney the chief of staff right saying
that we're just going they're never
going to get his tax returns when you
couple that with the fact that Donald
Trump just last week was asking agents
at the border to directly break the law
then you understand that we have a
president who is lawless who believes
he's above the law and believes that all
of this infrastructure all of these all
of this bureaucracy everyone who who
works for the federal government works
for him and not for the laws of the land
and that is the perfect combination to
see not only atrocities but to see the
overturning to see the undermining of
our nation in a way that we haven't seen
in a long time that we in a way that
we've never seen you know yeah I mean of
course the civil war comes to mind
however this is this is coming
directly from the president of the
united states and and while a lot of
this can be dismissed as people would
want to dismiss this as hyperbole it's
the little things man it really is the
little things that if Donald Trump was
able to get these border agents to break
the law in this manner right if he's
able to look at Congress to say I'm
simply going to ignore you those things
first of all they're not little but even
if you disregard them as being you know
insignificant then they simply you
cannot deny the fact that they add up to
the possibility of us undermining our
government in a way that we've never
seen right when you have armed forces so
to speak who are willing to ignore the
law of the land and simply do what the
president says that is a recipe for
disaster now I want to read a quote
here's a couple of quotes from CNN so
that you can get the full breadth and
depth of what the president was asking
at the border and then I want you to
compound that I want you to sit that
side-by-side juxtapose that to what the
president is saying through Mick
Mulvaney in terms of I'm just going to
ignore the Congress the president told
Agence agents via CNN not to let
migrants in quote last Friday the
president this this visited California
where he said we're full our systems
full our countries full you can't come
in our country is full why what can you
do we can't handle anymore
our country is full can't come in I'm
sorry it's very simple
behind the scenes two sources told CNN
the president told border agents not to
let migrants in tell them we don't have
the capacity he said if judges gives you
trouble say sorry judge I can't do it we
don't have the room after the president
left the room agents sought further
advice from their leaders who told them
that they were not giving them the
direction and if they did what the
president said they would take on
personal liability you have to follow
the law they were told this
fascinating I mean look at the mindset
of the President of the United States he
literally told them to go to a judge if
you get in trouble I want you to break
the law and if you get in trouble with
the judge tell the judge I said that
we're falling we can't come in it it's
mind-boggling that that this is okay to
a certain percentage of the electorate
it doesn't blow me away anymore that
this is who Donald Trump is it does not
blow me away that this is where we've
gotten to in this country what blows me
away is how we got here and the fact
that the people who support it Donald
Trump can look at this and say that it's
okay you know why they can look at this
and say that this is okay
because they are they are they're loyal
to Donald Trump and not the United
States of America this is a good place
as any there's a clip of a documentary
of Stephen not Steven Miller but uh
Steve Benning and Steve Bannon is at a
rally and there's a lady who stands up
in the crowd and she says she
essentially says no she precisely says
that she never thought she would want a
dictator but if she did if America did
have a dictator she would want it to be
Trump listening can you hand the mic to
the back yes ma'am
never in my life tonight let's get one
more question can you hand the mic to
the woman abacus ma'am never in my life
did I think I would like to see a G
dictator but if there's gonna be one I
want it to be Trump
it's unbelievable and it shows you the
power of the cult of personality it does
it shows you how tenuous American
democracy is in general right how how
how democracy can lean towards a
strongman it can leaning towards
dictators it leans toward hyper
partisanship which pushes people in the
corner so far and so wide that they will
swear allegiance even to the point of
undermining the nation right they will
swear allegiance to a dictator they will
swear allegiance to their political
figure it just shows you how tenuous and
how just how much democracy can hang on
by a thread especially when you have a
segment of the population who can be so
easily driven into this fury that
they're willing to turn over all
legality all since their rights in the
Constitution over to a person like
Donald Trump or over to anybody period
it's absolutely asinine I'm trying to
I'm trying to explain it and explain it
without being like you know so bombastic
about it but this is this is madness and
you have a segment of our of our
population who still today can look at
the president telling Border Patrol
agents to break the law who could look
at Congress and say I don't care what
you say I'm gonna do what I want to do
and then not only are they not offended
by this but they sit back and say yeah
that's our dude that's our guy
that's exactly the kind of leader we
want in fact if we went if we're gonna
have a dictator we would want it to be
Donald Trump yeah man listen I'm gonna
participate in the Democratic primaries
but whoever wins the primaries we better
get out there and vote all of these
people out of power because if we keep
empowering people like Donald Trump you
see the madness that is driving his
supporters and they don't care how far
he goes there is no limit we used to
think that he could get it well actually
I'm sorry it is actually true what they
said he can shoot somebody on Fifth
Avenue in New York City and his
supporters that 30 some odd percent a
huge
percentage of the boating electorate
still will support him one of today's
David Pakman show sponsors is simple
habit an app that provides a massive
library of really excellent 5 minute
guided meditations they're letting
everybody in our audience use it
completely free for one week when you go
to simple habit comm slash Pakman we've
talked a lot on the program about the
growing scientific evidence pointing to
the benefits of meditation and what
really sets simple habit apart is the
variety of guided meditations that they
offer more than 2,000 made for many
different issues that you may be dealing
with if you need help
falling asleep if you have anxiety that
you're dealing with if you want to be
more productive during the day they have
meditations specifically tailored for
certain times of day like when you're
waking up or your commute to work or
when you've just gotten home from work
I'm a huge advocate of meditation myself
I've really enjoyed integrating simple
habit into my day and each meditation
takes just five minutes and they're very
easy to follow maybe you want to feel
more grounded before you start your day
at work or at school maybe you want to
keep your mind a little more clear so
that it's easier to accomplish your
goals or you just want a calmer more
peaceful experience throughout your day
simple habit can help you get there it
just won the 2018 Google Play award for
best well-being app it's available on
Android iOS and web browser and you can
try it completely free for a week check
it out go to simple habit comm slash
Pakman I've put a link down below
underneath the video